the westerland's are all bounded by
three natural defenses mountain sea and
forest necessary barriers when the land
is as rich as ours from our minds come
the gold and silver that fuel the rest
of Westeros from Lannisport
our largest city can the most skillful
gold and silversmiths in the land yet
geography alone is not strength the
westerland's would have been sacked and
pillaged for thousands of years if it
hadn't been for the men who ruled it my
family House Lannister
according to legend we trace our descent
to lamb the clever a trickster of the
dawn age who swindled the castell ease
out of Casterly Rock their ancient
castle a childish story but not without
a married one a mind can and should be a
weapon in a man's arsenal to land must
have been clever enough not to rely
solely on his wits after all where today
is House Casterly three by keeping the
Castellon aim on the castle land
reminded the world of the price of
getting in his way the rains ignored all
these lessons not content with being the
second richest family they sought to
challenge the first mine my father had
put up with their insults and disrespect
when I came of age I led our army to
teach them what they should have known
some people say I was too harsh that
eradicating every member of their family
was not necessary
but now that I know Bannerman is loyal
to their Lord as the westerland's to us
if any Lord bridles of our authority I
have only to send a singer with a harp
and he falls back into line
because I will not have our Lord
squabble amongst themselves like the
lord of the Riverlands or hide in their
castles like the Lords of the Vale each
of our bannermen contributes a unique
skill that furthers the whole of the
westerland's us forgave because every
Lord needs a beast from time to time so
Gregor strikes terror into the hearts of
our enemies and our friends so too does
his disappointing brother sander the
traitor how Spain who provides us loyal
servants sir Ilyn Payne was once captain
of my household guard until the Mad King
heard him boast that I ran the Seven
Kingdoms which I did the Mad King tore
out sir Ellen's tongue making him
especially well-suited to later become
the King's justice apparently these days
a younger Payne also serves my
degenerate son
Tyrion House leopard who guards the
golden tooth the eastern pass through
the mountains and the all-too-frequent
chaos of the Seven Kingdoms
though after Robb Stark's recent
incursions perhaps we need a new
gatekeeper fools look at the West lands
and see gold fools see our wealth and
call it strength Gold is just another
Rock the westerland's are strong because
of House Lannister from strong
leadership comes unity from unity comes
power